e.t has learned that prince harry is
back in the uk
ahead the upcoming funeral for his
grandfather prince philip
from what i heard the sussex has found
out about prince philip's death at the
same time as everyone else it was sort
of a
unified approach from palace officials
to make sure
all rural family members were told at
the same time
the duke of edinburgh died on friday he
was 99.
yeah this has been a moment that i think
for many royal family members they would
have been gearing up to of course
there is a genuine sense of sadness but
at the same time
a celebration of a life that was lived
to its fullest
and of course a man who was not only the
dutiful consort to the queen
but also a loyal husband of 73 years
and i think that's really what the focus
is on today and on sunday
prince andrew provided some rare
comments to the press while exiting a
church service
where he called his father's death quote
a great loss
the duke of york told reporters quote we
have lost
almost the grandfather of the nation and
i feel very sorry and supportive of my
mother who was feeling it probably
more than everybody else she added quote
she's contemplating
is the way i would put it she described
it as having left a huge void in her
life
but we the family the ones that are
closer
are rallying around to make sure we are
there to support her
it's really about giving the queen her
only chance to finally put family before
juicy she has lived a life where juicy
always comes first
after the eight day period there's a
further 30 days of a lighter morning
period where the queen won't carry out
official rural engagements but she will
be involved in the day-to-day
rural activities of head of state so
it's a real mix of protocol but also
real sympathy for a woman who has just
lost her husband of 73 years
also on sunday sophie the wife of prince
edward
reflected on prince philip's final
moments the countess of wessex told
reporters his passing was quote
very very peaceful if there's one thing
that prince philip
made very clear during his life was that
he didn't want the fuss
around his funeral it was going to take
place in george's chapel
at windsor castle it's the same place
that harry and megan got married it's
also a place that's considered a family
chapel rather than a public
gathering space and so this will really
give a chance for the royals
to remember his life in a very peaceful
and quiet way
for harry who is so close to his
grandfather it's going to be a very
difficult time for him and while harry
is back in england
his wife meghan markle is remaining
stateside the duchess of sussex pregnant
with the couple's second child
did make every effort to be with her
husband but she was not given medical
clearance to travel from her physician
on top of that we of course are in the
middle of a pandemic that proves
difficult with restrictions of its own
and so i would imagine that there will
be a very likely scenario with that
harry is over here
representing the entire sussex family
megan archie
and himself as he pays respects to
prince philip in that final moment
and it will be a difficult moment
because i'm sure that megan would want
to be by harry's side for what will be a
very difficult time for him
[Music]
you